Sucuk getrocknete Tomaten Mais und
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
wir sind jetzt kurz vor Weihnachten kurz
vor Silvester der Jahreswechsel steht
bevor und vielleicht habt ihr noch
Wünsche was so die ein oder andere
Rezeptidee angeht deswegen gibt es heute
eine tolle Idee die ihr sowohl zu
Weihnachten als auch zu Silvester
zubereiten könnt ich mache das heute
allerdings nicht alleine ich habe mir
ein starkes paar zur Seite geholt und
zwar sind heute Ego und Sarah bei mir
mein traumhaft Instagram muss sein
unsere Freunde hallo
dieser wundervollen Küche ja die beiden
habt ihr im Doppelpack eigentlich bisher
nur im kitchen Video bei mir gesehen
bisschen gechillt und heute haben wir
uns gedacht Sarah soll auch auf jeden
Fall mit ich freue mich ja was ich hier
schon wieder sehe das ist wieder
internationale Küche hier ne natürlich
ja wir haben nämlich gedacht zu
Silvester sollte mal wieder was cooles
geben oftmals gibt der Raclette oder es
gibt Kartoffelsalat und Würstle was
gibt's bei euch so an Silvester
habt ihr so eine Tradition oder ist
immer anders es ist meistens immer
anders aber tendenziell immer das
Raclette ja ja auch oft macht aber das
fällt doch oft auf Weihnachten ist
Kürbissuppe
wenn wenn wir mal Zeit haben und alle zu
Hause sind dann macht sie meistens genau
oder ist noch offen also wir haben euch
auch dort gesehen wir gehen in einem
Bekannten Freizeitpark wahrscheinlich da
waren wir schon mal und das wollten wir
diesmal wieder machen in so ein weiß
nicht so ein Silvesterprogramm weil wir
wollten das für kleine auch auf seine
Kosten kommt und wir waren dort schon
mal da gibt es auch ganz tolle
Restaurants und so das heißt tagsüber
ist dann der kleine dran und abends wird
okay dann verraten wir jetzt am besten
nicht welcher Freizeitpark ja dann
ansonsten habt ihr dort Signierstunde
und mit dem greet aber du weißt ja
wahrscheinlich schon drüber ich habe mir
gedacht dass wir heute was machen was
Raclette ähnliches ist und zwar
partybrezeln also ich habe Brezeln schon
im Tiefkühlfach die habe ich gekauft die
habe ich nicht selber gemacht aber
dürfte natürlich auch selber machen und
zwar tiefkühlbrezeln die man einfach im
Ofen aufpackt und dann gibt es einfach
eine
Schmandmasse und man kann Zutaten
dazugeben jeder wie er möchte ich habe
jetzt mal Zutaten rausgelegt also ihr
braucht einfach für die Grundmasse 200 g
Schmand zwei Eier Salz Pfeffer gleich
alles verrührt und dann habe ich als
Toppings einfach noch Käse ich habe
Frühlingszwiebeln eine rote und grüne
Paprika Sucuk getrocknete Tomaten Mais
und
Eco Sarah dachte ich so Gemüse
ja doch bitte Ausgleich genau was kommt
bei Euch so beim Raclette noch rein wir
machen meistens noch Hähnchen Kartoffeln
geben wir noch rein und natürlich so
dieses typische Paprika Champignons okay
so ja aber bei mir ist noch so
Maiskolben diese Mini Maiskolben und
silberzwiebel das ist für mich so
Maiskolben Silberzwiebeln und Käse ist
meine absolute Lieblings Kombi
vielleicht gucke ich noch ob ich selber
Zwiebel und Maiskolben habe ich glaube
ich müsste welche haben Vorratsschrank
ja wenn ihr wollt legen wir los wir
bereiten einfach alles vor und schneiden
und dann kann jeder später so seine
Rätsel belegen werden oder darf ich
irgendwas für euch schneiden oder so
also ganz stark dass Du stark im
Zwiebelschneiden bist vom letzten Mal
sieht schon mal sehr sehr gut aus
kann es wäre super lieb wenn ihr mir
sagt wie wie dick die sein dürfen
die dürfen darfst du einfach in schöne
feine Ringe schneiden so bis hier
ungefähr oder bis zum Schluss
und ich verrühre einfach Schmand mit dem
Eiern Salz und Pfeffer und wer will kann
er noch Knoblauch dazugeben weiß nicht
wie ihr das so sieht mit Knoblauch also
ich esse sehr sehr gerne Knoblauch wir
hauen da immer sehr sehr viel rein ich
mache ja ja
gegessen haben
wir wollten uns eigentlich früher
treffen aber dann ging es bei uns
gesundheitlich nicht haben was
verschoben eigentlich wollte ich mit dir
was typisches zu Weihnachten machen
weil ich mir dachte eigentlich ist da
voll witzig wenn quasi wir zwei die aus
dem türkischen Haushalt kommen was zu
Weihnachten machen und ich werde immer
jedes Jahr gefragt das heißt dann immer
okay und wieso macht ihr das und warum
und ihr seid doch keine Christen und ich
habe dann immer erklärt bei uns früher
war es schon so meine Eltern sind beide
aus der Türkei beide aus einer
muslimischen Haushalt aber bei uns gab
es trotzdem
zusammengebacken und es war einfach
immer schön es hatte nicht so den
religiösen Hintergrund das hat ja auch
was traditionelles Tradition ist ja
nicht immer gleich Religion und wir
haben das auch zelebriert zu Hause
meine Mutter wollte zum Beispiel dass
wir den anderen Kindern in der Schule
nichts nachstehen und wenn die dann
kommen und erzählen wie das war und so
dann nicht dass wir traurig werden da
haben wir auch immer was bekommen
irgendwie sie hat dann versucht und so
so eine Art Weihnachtsmann aber eher so
eine
top-pflanze und Strauch und
weihnachtsstrauch und dann runter hat
sie dann Geschenke getan also wir haben
das auch immer gefallen
den gibt's auch eine Türkei das heißt ja
nur weil bei Roman und ich glaube das
ist einfach was weltweites was wir alle
zusammen feiern können weil es geht um
Familie es geht um Liebe ne und es geht
darum dass wir
teilen miteinander und dass man die gute
Werte vermitteln
zu schätzen weiß was man hat so und ich
glaube das hat keine Nationalität
ja das ist perfekt
packen
in der Türkei gibt es auch einen
Weihnachtsbaum der heißt halt dort
neujahrsbaum da wird es auch immer schön
dekoriert und alles und bei euch war
Weihnachten immer so ganz traditionell
ja bei uns in ursprünglich in Polen
haben wir natürlich alles super
zelebriert also gefühlt bin bin ich
irgendwie ein Monat vorher am schmücken
und alles am Vorbereiten also wir machen
das immer sehr traditionell aber wie wir
gelernt haben von meiner Community immer
nach toten Sonntag ja wir haben da immer
hate abgekriegt weil sie ist nicht
fortpfoten Sonntag aber ich muss sagen
man muss ja jeden Tag den Toten gedenken
und nicht nur einmal im Jahr von daher
erlaube ich es mir auch vorher schon so
dekorieren und das ist für mich so wenn
es Lebkuchen gibt aber August dann finde
ich auch nicht erkennen
ich liebe Weine voll gerne so ein
Weihnachtslied also vor allen Dingen die
kleinen Namen macht total Spaß da das
geht ja auch so durch durch die durch
die ganze Gesellschaft also alle Leute
sind in so einer Stimmung und du bist zu
Hause es ist so schön gemütlich im
besten Fall es schneits oder sowas das
Moment bisschen schwer aber ihr wisst
was ich meine es ist schön
schönes Zusammensein Kerzen überall an
genau
wenn du willst kannst du noch Sucuk
bisschen schneiden
oder vierteln kannst du auch sowas
geht muss ich sagen weil wir holen jetzt
gleich die Brezeln raus belegen alles
und zack fertig und da kann man sich
überlegen ob man das mit seinen Gästen
oder mit der Familie zusammen macht und
jeder seine Brezel gelegt oder ob man es
eben dann schon vorbereitet
und bei Sarah finde ich also toll Sarah
setzt sich ja so ganz krass für
Frauenrechte ein und du hattest jetzt
auch ein Prozess mit begleitet der mir
auch sehr nah ging von der Terrier die
mit ihrem Sohn ermordet wurde wo ich so
bei jedem Posting dass du geteilt hast
ein Fluss im Hals habe und eigentlich
nicht drüber reden kann weil es so
schlimm ist
weil du ja einfach sagst dass Gewalt
gegen Frauen bis heute noch leider immer
noch tagtäglich auf dem Programm steht
seit ein Thema was krass
gesellschaftlich als Problem noch da ist
und ich glaube dass oder ich versuche
dadurch dass ich immer wieder darauf
aufmerksam mache und ich weiß das ist
kein schönes Thema kein positives Thema
es fällt mir ja selber auch schwer aber
ich glaube je mehr ich das mache dass du
sensibler ist die Gesellschaft
irgendwann und hat halt nicht mehr dass
das Gefühl dass es so weit weg ist weißt
du wie ich meine also das scheint immer
so weit aber es passiert tatsächlich
irgendwie in der Nachbarschaft
ich glaube dass wir uns dessen einfach
bewusst werden müssen ich meine sprechen
ja gerade viel über den Iran wo es ja
wirklich ganz radikal auch öffentlich
gemacht wird Frau Gewalt gegen Frauen wo
Frauen einfach ermordet werden weil sie
so sind wie sie sind oder aussehen wie
sie aussehen aber was in Deutschland
oder in vielen anderen Ländern halt
immer noch tagtäglich ist ist auch die
die psychische Gewalt gegen Frauen also
diese Unterdrückung dieses unter Druck
setzen ist für alles verantwortlich und
ich glaube da haben viele Frauen die
vielleicht auch so krass modern aussehen
und man denkt so eine gestandene Frau
die hat ihr Leben voll im Griff dabei
ist vielleicht hinter den Kulissen
einfach gar nicht so und da finde ich
gut dass du dich dafür einsetzt danke
schön
mein Podcast rüber und das ist einfach
ein Thema was zu viele noch
noch unterschätzen tatsächlich ihr geht
ja auch beide mit guten Beispiel voran
das finde ich besonders toll bei Euch
beiden weil ihr auch als weiß nicht als
Frauen die auch nach vorne gehen und was
selber auf die Beine stellen
wahrgenommen werdet und deswegen finde
ich toll ja
Männlichkeit
en dazu sage ich jetzt nicht darf ich
hier diese diese dieses was ich
abgefriemelt habe ich schon Essen
zubereitet zu Glück ist ein
Grundnahrungsmittel
das gehört definitiv
zu Hause hat das geht einfach so nicht
mehr weg aus ja guck mal die Tomaten
können wir auch noch schneiden einfach
so eine kleine Scheiben ja und dann hole
ich schon mal die Brezeln
[Musik]
ich habe noch die Zwiebeln bekommen
der Eco liebt es tatsächlich bei uns zu
Hause Bauernsalat zu machen ich weiß
nicht woher diese neue Eigenschaft kommt
aber sie ist da ich mag Bauernsalat sehr
gerne das kommt glaube ich auch wieder
aus der türkischen
Sozialisierung irgendwie so aus der
Familie ich liebe diese Kombination
einfach Tomate
Gurke weiße Käse also ein bisschen
Frühlingszwiebeln kann man auch ein
bisschen Wasser variieren einfach lecker
das ist so lecker wenn das gut mit Essig
und Öl also so gute gute Mischung ist da
kann man das als kann ohne Ende Essen
eigentlich gefunden
nächstes Jahr dann im Sommer so ein
bisschen was im Garten anzupflanzen oh
ja ich hätte gerne ein Hochbeet hinten
also wirklich so diese Standard Sachen
weil ich finde es ganz cool für den
eliaser dass er halt auch einfach sieht
woher alles kommt und auch so ein
bisschen sensibler darauf hat ne die
Ella die im Sommer immer in die
Hochbeete wenn die tomatensträuche
Erwachsene und er Tomaten dadurch auch
das ist toll
also wenn ihr Hilfe braucht beim
Hochbeet war nicht chicoras vorbei sehr
gut
sind genau gleich alt und ja voll gut
verstanden letztes mal schon die doch
schon direkt nach ihm gefragt aber heute
auch kommen
ich fühle mich
wie so ein Sushi
so bitteschön ach so das ist auch jetzt
so dünn ja ich würde fast sagen ja
Kompliment noch mal ihr habt so tolle
Kinder Sally was die die
welchen Sohn hätte würde ich mir
wünschen dass er so ist wie
talentiert auf die Samira ist
unglaublich wie die da synchronisiert
hat bei dem einen Film dachte wow wie
hört sich das denn an das hört sich an
wie als hätte sie nie was anderes
gemacht tatsächlich viel viel viel
besser gemacht als ich weil Kinder die
denken da nicht drüber nach wie sehe ich
da dabei aus wie wie artikuliere ich
mich jetzt Kinder sind da einfach so so
cool die machen es einfach die denken da
nicht drüber nach und die stand da hat
er ihre kompletten Emotionen reingepackt
toll wo ich irgendwie fünf Anläufe
gebraucht habe aber länger gedauert
in dem Alter so vor ganz Deutschland zu
singen in so einem Tonstudio ganz
alleine das war toll schon Wahnsinn
Teil mit mir
diesen Traum
an meine Süße Zukunft glaube ich glaube
ja ich habe das jetzt hier die das
mittlere so gut es geht da
rausgeschrieben
ich glaube wir brauchen größeres Gefäße
ja ich nehme eigentlich immer angemessen
große Schüsseln aber das war jetzt
diesmal so ein FuPa
ja perfekt dann können wir eigentlich
schon ich nehme eure Schneidebretter
einfach weg und dann können wir da die
Bleche holen
oder einfach in den Hintergrund heute
ja guck mal so schön kann man das ja
auch anrichten wenn man dann eben
gemeinsam die Brezeln belegen möchte das
sieht schon total lecker
so dann könnt ihr gerne die Bleche holen
und dann können wir da die Brezeln drauf
machen
ihr natürlich schon auch gesund zu Hause
ne ja wir versuchen es zumindest also
wir achten schon da drauf dass wir genug
Nährstoffe kriegen relativ wenig
Kohlenhydrate also das heute ist schon
ein bisschen so Cheat day mit Brezel und
Schmandcreme aber ist okay oder für
Silvester Weihnachten
ich bin echt weg von morgen Brot
frühstücken klar ab und zu mal ich mache
doch keine eigene Brote aber bei uns
früher zu Hause gab es jeden Tag Brot
zum Frühstück und ich verkaufe das gar
nicht also meine Verdauung dass das
macht gar nicht mit ich brauche auch mal
Porridge oder was flüssiges irgendwie
Müsli was leicht ist das leichte
aber das machen wir auch ne also machen
wir auch schon mal Porridge gut wenn es
schnell geht dann essen wir mal ein
Vollkornbrot ne ja gut
genau hier könnt ihr einfach eure Brezel
nehmen
sagt die muss man jetzt nicht unbedingt
selber machen weil es auch ein bisschen
übertrieben muss man sagen für so ein
Rezept und dann ich glaube die müssen
einmal umdrehen dass die flache Seite
unten raus genau dass die nicht ausläuft
und ich dachte mir wir nehmen dann
einfach diese Füllung so okay so gehen
wir ab Alter
und dann kann jeder so seine Toppings
reinmachen sehr gut willst du anfangen
oder fragst
wollen wir das so mit den Händen oder
braucht Ihr Löffel
sind ja gewaschen
als ich nehme auf jeden Fall Zwiebel und
Mais
und das ist jetzt nur Käse und Schmand
und Salz Pfeffer
ja also relativ schnell tatsächlich zu
machen man kommt nicht in den Stress den
man ansonsten an Silvester oder
Weihnachten hat man braucht nur so ein
bisschen
Platz im Tiefkühlfach für die Brezeln
aber wir haben jetzt auch zwei Päckchen
gekauft die gab es tatsächlich auch beim
Lidl einfach im Tiefkühlfach zum
Aufbacken und dann hat man ja alles
andere schon da
es lohnt sich ich bin so der
veggietyp deswegen ich lieb getrocknete
Tomaten so als Fleischersatz
ich glaube Samira und Ella die werden so
bei Mais meistens
also du bist in der Typ also du
versuchst es zu gehen oder bist du
jetzt schon auch gerne mal Fleisch und
Milchprodukte und so weiter aber ich
achte drauf nicht so viel und Sucuk ist
so ein Ding wo ich sage okay das ist
eine Ausnahme das ist okay aber
ansonsten gucken wir schon das ist
Fleisch immer eine gute Herkunft hat ja
das machen wir auch so lokalmäßig
reduziert einfach
Massen sondern eher qualitativ gut
und man könnte das sogar süß zubereiten
denn die Brezeln an sich das schmeckt ja
auch immer gut wenn man Brezel hat dann
die Schmandcreme mit bisschen
Puderzucker und Vanilleextrakt und dann
zum Beispiel die zweite Portion so okay
wir machen noch eine zweite Person okay
und dann zum Beispiel gefrorene
Himbeeren dann ein bisschen Mandeln
drauf und dann habt ihr noch süße
Brezeln aber wo kriegen wir jetzt das
vanilleextraktiv
das sieht echt lecker
[Musik]
das ist doch richtig finde das war auch
eine coole Idee für so Bäckereien so
Brezel mit Topping der neue Trend Brezel
mit Topping jetzt neu in brezelsdorf
deutschlandweit
jetzt Schüler nichts sagen aber ich
hatte letztes Jahr hatte ich Cheesecakes
Steaks gemacht mit so verschiedenen
Toppings und kurz drauf gab es Läden die
dann eröffnet haben mit Cheesecakes
immer aufgefallen
immer eine Inspiration
aber Kochen inspiriert auch und es
verbindet auch
du arbeitest ja auch regelmäßig mit
meinem alten Schulfreund ne ja
hat ja auch nicht
später angefangen zu kochen wie schön
das einfach ist ja
und essen muss halt doch irgendwo jeder
ja voll gut
in der Mitte die ist noch nicht fertig
und trocknen würde ich sagen packen wir
die in den Backofen wir machen gleich
noch eine süße Variante die gibt es aber
als Shorts und auf dem Kanal findet ihr
die dann auf sallys-block.de oder in der
App als Rezept und dann gehen wir an
unseren Podcast wenn das Video jetzt
heute online geht ist der Podcast auch
schon online das heißt falls ihr den
noch nicht gehört habt einmal bei Eco wo
findet man den Podcast den findet man
ausschließlich in der ARD Audiothek
einfach mal Auschecken genau
wir leben beispielsweise Punkte
Ernährung gesund das habe ich eben ja
schon gesagt größtenteils durch Sarah
erfahren vielleicht hätte ich auch so
irgendwann erfahren aber vielleicht wäre
es auch zu spät gehen wenn du krank bist
das ist einfach was wir so durchziehen
ich merke auch dass Essen coole
Belohnung ist das z.B etwas wie wir sind
wirklich nicht verschwenderisch ne wegen
wir geben selten Geld für irgendwas auch
bei Essen gucke ich nicht drauf wir
gehen gerne mal das ist einzige sag mal
was für uns zu gönnen wir gehen gerne
mal schön Essen wo wir uns auch so
ein teures Restaurant gehen weil es
einfach gut schmeckt oder gut zubereitet
ist oder was auch immer das ist so aus
unserer Sicht also das ist wir sehen
noch Ernährung irgendwie als eine
Belohnung ich habe manchmal so eine
Schwierigkeit da dran das in den Tag
krass gesund irgendwie einzubauen
vielleicht habt ihr da irgendwie Tipps
für uns für dich Zuhörer und
ZuhörerInnen
so dreckiger die Pommesbude umso geiles
die Pommes
ja weißt du schon schwierig wenn man den
ganzen Tag arbeitet dann sich noch
gesund zu ernähren und wenn wir jetzt
nur zu Hause wären bei uns daheim und im
Studio dann kriege ich es echt noch gut
hin dann hast du so eine Routine dein
Alltag du kannst dir dein dein Frühstück
am Abend schon vorbereiten irgendwie ein
Porridge oder overnight Müsli oder
irgendwas die Kinder machen das auch
selbstständig tatsächlich Ella mit ihren
sieben Jahren macht ihr früher selber
die Samira macht das selber ist ein
bisschen weniger tatsächlich als die
Ella da merkt man schon beim Kindern so
ein bisschen Unterschied aber wenn es
dann bei uns auch darum geht wir haben
irgendwie Termine oder wir sind irgendwo
in einem Filmstudio oder am Set da merkt
man schon es gibt setzt die haben
richtig gutes Catering und die haben
auch gesundes Essen aber dann gibt's
halt auch Sets beim Fernsehen muss man
sagen ah da wird halt schon am Essen
gespart und dann gibt's halt viel
Kantine essen und die geht ja doch bei
einzelnen Filmen hatte ich das schon
aber meistens stelle ich mich schon
drauf ein da gibt's essen was zu arg
verarbeitet ist viel zu viel Teig waren
zu wenig frisches Gemüse und so ein
Salatblatt das Deck gar nicht den
Nährstoffbedarf das heißt da gucke ich
dann immer schon und das so der Tipp den
ich jedem geben kann wenn man weiß man
ist nicht zu Hause man hat vielleicht
keine Küche in der man was machen kann
dann esse ich einfach ganz viel Rohkost
also ich gehe dann wirklich zum
Supermarkt und hole mir dann meinen
Sellerie meine Karotten meine Gurken
alles was grad saisonal ist an Gemüse
und Obst und das hole ich dann und das
knabber ich dann halt den ganzen Tag
natürlich esse ich dann auch was warmes
und ist irgendwie eine Portion aber das
ist so wo ich dann weiß ich habe jetzt
Vitamine für den Tag und die nicht
einfach nur durch Tabletten oder
nahrungsergänzen sondern wirklich durch
Obst und Gemüse und das kann glaube ich
jeder also da finde ich darf sich keiner
rausreden und sagen ich komme nicht an
gesunde Lebensmittel dran
ja dann kann man verschiedene Breze mal
im Text Max Brezeln
oder
Text Max cool
bisschen französisch mit Weichkäse
vielleicht habt ihr auch noch weitere
Ideen
genau machen wir einfach weiter
gleichzeitig rein Heißluft einmal hier
genau und dann gerade unten hier oder
perfekt super
bekommen
da haben wir sie doch unsere Brezeln gut
aus sieht schon gut aus ich finde das
richtig aus
servierpalette ja
Mama wir sind doch gleichberechtigt
deswegen finde ich du bist der Herr in
der Runde du darfst jetzt erstmal sehen
[Musik]
das riecht so gut dann nehme ich mir
auch einfach raus ja man kann ja auch so
richtig so Flammkuchen Style auch machen
soll ich die drauf geben oder ja gerne
ich würde dann die nehmen die mit mit
selber Zwiebeln
danke schön
könnt ihr euch das vorstellen dass ihr
das so auch an Silvester oder ein Partys
oder irgendwie macht ja ich finde das
kann man wirklich sehr sehr gut machen
es geht relativ schnell und ohne viel
Aufwand du kannst dich eventuell auch
mit den Gästen dann dabei unterhalten
wenn sie dann schon früher da sind also
schon super ja und die Kids können Ihre
Pizza Brezel oder ihre partybrezel
einfach selber belegen dann essen sie
zumindest auch echt ein guter Tipp Sally
ich kann mir ich will mich nicht wundern
wenn es das bald überall gibt ein Leben
leben
ich weiß gar nicht wie es nennen soll
raclettebrezel partybrezel
flammkuchenbrezel pizzabrezel ist so
alles gell
du bist doch hier das wandelnde Lexikon
partybrezel mit Toppings Party
und ich finde es könnte man sogar kalt
essen ja
cool also hier die herzhafte Version die
süße Version haben wir auch für euch
abgedreht die ist noch im Backofen aber
schmeckt bestimmt auch hervorragend gut
und dann bedanken wir uns fürs
Einschalten schön dass ihr zwei dauert
also ihr könnt echt echt öfter
vorbeikommen ja natürlich
setzen kann man ganz in Ruhe essen
also macht's gut und ich wünsche euch
jetzt schon mal schöne Weihnachten das
steht jetzt vor der Tür unten schönen
Jahreswechsel
[Musik]